yeah all right welcome to a new video um
I'll be doing something slightly
different today i'll be doing a couple
of three minute games on icc i just
noticed that i haven't played any year
so I'm furious with what rating olds
thought actually I should be should be
pretty basic rating and I'll do a couple
of games started I do a couple of games
in this video not just one game okay
let's start out one year form and let's
see what happens I've philidor defense
let's see what black does he takes on
deform this is some an interesting line
for black actually it's a pretty solid a
bit passive but um it can be be be quite
sharp if white castles long and black
shot okay i'll be going for a long
castling here okay avoided the exchange
on deform maybe wants to play c5 i want
to be ready to go here don't want to
retreat the night okay now he may be
intense to to play something like be
five I want to run security a two-point
and also maybe threaten 9595 young I
could go 95 now 95 Queen takes or what I
would have the intermediate check here
hmm this was also an idea of King be one
that this is not a check on d 2 so I
needs to retreat now too oops
not sure if this was an oversight or
real sacrifice black resign okay didn't
it didn't see this sometimes this kind
of sacrifice even as an idea but I could
take a for now it would have two pieces
it should be enough here really because
their fall night doesn't have a decent
Richard retreat square so maybe I can
just play Queen d2 a Tekkit and it
doesn't have any good square needs to
yeah maybe go back to h5 ye could play
Bishop g5 but this could easily be
yourself pin ok I'm the next game I
don't have a button here ok where I
gained 385 rating points with this with
this game from 1600 to nineteen nineteen
eighty-five it it's always really
dynamic in the first couple of games so
let's see what's coming up next and I
hope I'm not waiting too long it's maybe
not the ideal time to gain the star
games ok opponent is called bronze from
Sweden cara cara cara con and i play a
3d fantasy variation i'm not quite sure
why it's called the fantasy variation
but it leads to interesting plane ok it
cover here or maybe you can take now and
give this check yeah I'm not really an
expert I just saw I'm recently a couple
of games with this line I thought that
it looked interesting ok now I can I
think just develop with effort to come
and this is very similar now to a French
defense only difference is I have got
the night on e 2 and not on f3 otherwise
this would be almost identical to a
typical on French main line
he takes on the phone all night x we
would again have a French position okay
it's a French type position anyway but
really am almost like a pure
transposition okay it seems to on
prepare b5 not quite sure how to develop
him I could take off course yeah ok
let's take here I don't see any other
way to get my bishop developed so take
care 94 next it's not ideal but like
mentioned how else do do I get my bishop
into play you can sometimes play g3
Bishop 83 or a g2 g3 Bishop tutu but I'm
not sure this is a good plan here so now
i can now just simply develop yeah ok
the sun was designed to allow b5 now
it's an interesting question if i should
go before they ever I like this idea now
yeah it has to retreat passively or play
Knight a form
yeah I think you should play 9 a-4
really hmm but then it's an interesting
question if I should take ok ok this was
a squares well of course ok ok let's
move I need to play anyway at some point
stabilize here the bishop and TM intense
a five anyway ok this move a taxi 4 and
a 7 i'm not quite sure ok if I it's not
really threatened maybe because Bishop
c6 would attack the g2 porn but in the
long run I can try to to grab this pawn
we rooting this bishop maybe to see two
or something and then attack and win
this porn you will need to play a five
or something to to protect it and this
Bishop is nicely positioned sir it's
protected cannot be attacked and also
covers all kinds of important parts of
whites position ok but now I'm
reconsidering I can take because Bishop
c6 Queen III Bishop g2 I have rooted g1
and detect g7 ok it's somewhat messy of
course but pawn is a pawn and g7 well
it's not clear who's king is worse here
but I can I can I think usually go to d
two words no issue should be should be
pretty safe here I've got lots of pieces
around the king and he doesn't have
anything to take it yeah maybe justice
this one idea route g8 look some
difficult for black
okay rook g8 now okay we can always go
to to descend maybe I should prepare f5
also opening the pollution more yeah
this is hanging no on a three is this a
problem not sure okay I'll do this first
of all hi morning yeah I don't have so
much time but he's Union more down on
the clock he can take here but it's just
a check end and this show should give
serious threats now ya know I have queen
d 3 if he takes yet squinty-eyed mate
black for fits on time yeah you for
fighting on shine but this is made now
ok yeah strange transportation
transposition into the French structure
ok let's see what's coming up next this
still netted not 18 aging point started
ok Mobutu I I've got white again this is
unusual free whites in a row oh this
looks like a mouse lip hmm now taking I
couldn't I could I could take just don't
have six but
yeah let's just simply retreat here no
I'm a porn up maybe just f3 and
preparing lon Castle you let's just a
pawn for nothing and I can try to win
space here soon okay maybe g3 Bishop h3
this looks like a desirable exchange to
get rid of the light squared bishops
okay let's grab here and now now what a
form maybe even okay I need to be
cautious this kind of move might even
open up his bishop so maybe first some
more preparation of the smooth f1
it really doesn't have any active
possibilities okay but now I'm of course
tempted to you can open the queenside up
I'm sure what what's the idea we end
this I can just go to be three now the
Taffer huge advantage Sun on the
queenside as well okay I could even just
play c3 here yeah why not and now c5c
for immediately would also have been
good I think yeah this was to be
expected at some point he needed to do
something wrong even if it's not really
helpful but you cannot well wait until
wide execute okay what now I could I
could bring this night to reform would
be nice positionally or open it up with
FYI think opening it opening it up
should be right after all he's got them
not to secure king I need to be yeah
this is the sort of the last idea that
white has in this position trying to to
get in a check here okay time morning
this is actually somewhat annoying
down to 40 seconds so of course I'm not
to mentally astok about rook a one but I
needed to get any move relatively
quickly Queenie 523 it's not so
problematic be to singing but this
doesn't matter so much to cover this
yeah you just place on time as usual
people don't really want to play good
news yeah it's of course problematic
because of the time I just gave away the
spawn I'm still better in this end game
oh it's just a question if I manage the
time that I was an understatement white
is just winning but time with the issue
check check check check
cha-cha-cha at least I secured the dog
the draw here yeah I was just a bit slow
this was yeah well maybe I should have
tried to win it somehow but it was fun
at two to get the draw just because of
the time yeah King e5 now obviously this
is better what didn't I do this no idea
well after this 93 before just Nets the
pawn ok let's go for the next game a joy
to play star somewhat quicker k 1 you
form let's go for Sicilian here ok I've
got the Conn variation try to make use
of this Bishop sometimes black even can
can launch some funny stuff like this H
594 I try this maybe not one hundred
percent correct but if it it's it leads
to interesting play I think we can of
course go h3 but this doesn't really
involve a threat then because taking hg
is always a check ok can i play be five
there should be seven keep backing in
the middle for for longer maybe
sometimes white just lashes out was 95
yeah if a player should be 70 v play 95
funny ok maybe get the key out of the
leaf i'll of course this is dubious for
black
no need to be overly optimistic here
black ass gambling here ok Mary Knight
to f5 can I get this Knight to f5 I was
more expecting Bishop before move like
this ok but let's see what happens here
at least I've got nice bishops ok this
was the idea didn't didn't really
appreciate that ok cannot move the night
no Amanda pin ok let's cover this and
maybe go King g8 next
yeah sorry very complicated position
most likely it's bad for me fi okay but
you can play a 5 now maybe at five mmm
would have been interesting let's see
what happens now he just takes it okay
yeah this way also blocks to this
business Bishop certainly am a useful
idea maybe I can play just King g7 and
and get a more normal position so to say
trying to get the rook also back into
and to play I can also drop back the
night okay this is not threatening at
the moment so i can i can wait a bit
with retreating you know I need to ok ok
h Shrivers also hanging so the question
is morning maybe
okay I'll draw page five so I was
helping on that I could open the bishops
here now if he takes with the night at
least it takes with the bishop well at
least I've got two bishops now actively
placed look h3 it's sometimes and a
trick tricking idea here but I need to
if possible both rocks I just 98 silly
or this one so I double double check
yeah okay yeah you can just give the
check here and then take the Queen and
it's over okay didn't do this what what
is this I'm still I'm still losing him
you have to look down but this has no
square so yeah we needed to check this
yeah i'm just playing on a couple of
buttons of course to totally lost so
sorry it's not not so clear-cut
checkmate yeah what can you do yeah I
was a steady okay I guess not solid
enough this position of course I've
landed but all in all the sir didn't
look too solid all right
game started okay a black game against
Reggie what is playing you form yeah the
Sicilian didn't really really work out
last time yeah well it's a three minute
game cannot think all day let's play
five what I always play ok and now this
cool counter gambit let's see how it is
doing in three minutes tough against a
few master I usually test it I just
tested this in Rose war zone tab
tournaments and it worked out pretty
well down okay I'm checking the five
night let's see what is doing okay I
want to get the pawn back of course
support maybe he could yeah you could
try this move securing the pawn maybe
this is so a good idea okay let's let's
attack this straight away I know you
would most likely continue Bishop 83 m
if I ever go down but not much choice I
think yeah pretty unique position I
think Bishop h3 now he needs to protect
the spawn if he just lets me retake it
I'm just clearly better okay could we
could go see for maybe him first yeah
okay he needs to you need to protect and
now what Queen f7 maybe
I really want this back it's not just a
matter of a porn but I need to I need
this square so to develop my pieces
properly
let's say g6 I just have Queen f6 this
doesn't really look 22 threatening just
on the contrary maybe c4 not quite sure
I think yeah okay it tries to attack me
for maybe I take here take stakes and
then night something's night somewhere
hmm I can go King December now and try
to play a quick rookie aid our this move
checks here okay the king should be
quite ok down so what now it's not
really threatening anything question is
what what to do with the special ball so
I could also just take and play D 5 D
556 not bad ok let's do this yeah it
should just be ok for me ok what now III
may be opening up the Evalia if he takes
rook e8 looks dangerous ok maybe can
take but I first protect the spawn this
should really irritate him
how to suggest a move maybe just
threatening to take on air for almost
close close to to the threat at least
time morning k okay three threads there
they don't have direct made or something
so let's just retake it now maybeee to
coming e to would go to need to go to g1
now after a two but okay this will
decide it by time okay manage long
castles but i can go into where the
surface s1 so
alright calm is really to mate check
check white forfeits all the time yeah
it just as Queen d1 and Queen text you
want checkmate yeah this opening again
proof that it's at least tricky for
white the crazy f5 line okay one more
game game started with white let's get
going for again oh it's pretty high
rated 2300 something and he's from who
had to recall oh that's fun yeah the fun
thing is here lies to see it's different
if you know chess cube you've got people
on giving wrong countries all the time
so you get I don't know the US Virgin
Islands or whatever the Christmas
islands and in fact they're all playing
from I don't know the UK or the US or
something because you can just choose
your country or your country flag yeah
to your liking it let's no proof or
something behind this and on as you see
it's different they actually determine
the flag from your arm from your
internet connection so as long as I'm
playing from from Germany always have
the German flag here um if I travel to
another country i will get the flag of
the country that I'm playing from so
yeah i'll be on vacation starting
tomorrow and if i play on icc from from
my own yeah from my place I'm staying in
my vacation I'll get another flag ok um
he's attacking be too we've got some
night off here and there really not sure
what what the theory is maybe I already
something wrong okay I really can't
stand the night down for a long long
time but it looks somewhat annoying
already didn't like to surrender the
bishop pair of course not sure where to
go maybe you can even get in a quick d5
now open it up for for the bishops now
something went wrong there buts okay i'm
not a huge expert on the open decision
of course maybe prevent b5 for the time
being this would have been a possibility
also the last move rook c8 and was fine
of course but ok let's drop this back
the night isn't doing anything on b3
anyway so now maybe 94 threatened i can
prevent this for the time being so now
maybe here trying to
get the d5 square
yeah black is most likely completely
okay here he s st five ideas anyway
would love to play Knight c4b 65 but not
sephora has the idea of taking on a
phone all the time
time warning maybe the snow right Bishop
be fallin 9 p-6 he could play this as a
second core of course a sacrifice but if
he doesn't know I'll have a great
position ok this moves also possible 95
or taking Knight b6 Queen tags
I'm not quite sure ok
okay well not what moved you want to
make yeah of course my night is
completely helpless this went downhill
quickly I wasn't so bad I think at first
yeah okay 10 seconds I can just resign
this quite resigned it's hard to but
this I'm not sure there should be some
way to get a decent position here
somehow at least um I ridiculous i can
just take on see for now and now not
taking here but just not see three after
this i don't have any problems the ieee
computer gives a quite big advantage to
black buttons i don't simply don't
believe 93 rupee for okay to rook c8 and
i look Leah but this is playable I might
lose a pawn on the queenside but I'll
get this knight on d5 and I can always
fight this okay it's may be okay for
black or better for black but this would
have been better than the game of course
okay next game
game started right you fall okay let's
let's change a bit here and let's see
what happens here in this French okay i
try to try a funny movie h6 the idea
will be revealed later like is waiting
for one move and tries to ya get this
kind of position here right now h6
really serves the purpose what usually
cast lots now what else is there yeah
now g5 white has other moves maybe a
three or something but this was the idea
playing playing g5 in the structure
their ideas to put pressure on the d4
point so maybe it's simply advancing g4
and then grabbing the pawn okay now
black has a choice I can recapture in
multiple ways and I can also go with g4
first the guy I'll grab this pawn
another point of age 6 g 5 is that in
this kind of position I could also go
Bishop g7 there's a similar line with
bishop on e 7 but in comparison on the
advantage is that i have this Bishop g7
move mmm Bishop c2 Can I grab c5 come on
I'm cheeky I'm grabbing this as well
this is not really solid for black but
ok come on maybe I should have dropped
back to be 6 like a plant initially yeah
just because because of this the smooth
mmm yeah dangerous of course oh I
completely overlooked that you can take
here well this can get this can get
really ugly this can get ugly
Oh what's wrong what kind of moves do I
even have that it can play
yeah of course what just has a super
strong attack for almost nothing so
maybe I can get the King into safety at
least King moves Bishop d7 look at seven
castles yeah maybe this is not an
immediate loss wouldn't be surprised
though if there that would be 11
devastating move one point is rook f
seven castles route is seven I've got
Luke f1 mate so I'm Luke f7 I can
backhand castle and not do something
immediately but from yeah it's it's
equal material funny enough but well he
can can also just just take h6 but ok
I'm just noticing that he's really down
on the clock so on this is will be the
morning we decided here didn't pay much
attention to the clock before it's down
on three seconds so unless I'm
blundering to 2am ATM I will win on time
white foreheads on time yeah I guess
this was a bit too complicated for for
both players but ok you shouldn't really
overstep the time after 20 moves ok next
one well we on 40 minutes now in this
video I think I'll play one more game to
have a video of close to 45 minutes and
I'm sorry I'm got a slight coach Jim
game started okay um I played a couple
of e 4 cm okay let's go d form from the
last game ok some sort of baloney so
yeah we need to go what the f night here
other moves lose 35 yeah I'm trying tag
here with f5 Bishop age 60 k immediately
goes esox tries to prevent this here
maybe i can i can capture here play this
moves taking the night also taking both
porn so yeah I think you needed to take
and now a 7 is a weakness
I couldn't I can go see 42 okay let's
let's check this quickly c4 is not
always a desirable move here this also
might be a good post for peace at one
point but okay now think I need a secure
protection of the d5 pawn maybe not f6
roop 37 now this is this idea most
likely okay I'll take one off here
to prevent some annoying checks IAM
g-form yeah but I thought I can just
take a night eh for this just weeks f5
and this is really just a check not much
more the night actually doesn't have any
any square to go to either things
protected and you know you can just take
you know the night is hanging and just
as hanging also black forfeits due to
disconnection uh-huh yeah the poor man's
way of resigning is disconnecting yeah
he disconnected and and resigned to this
way yeah I think some some quick maybe
some interesting games in a three minute
format here on icc yeah thanks for
watching and yeah well i will be on
vacation starting tomorrow for um for
nine days yeah and i'm not quite sure
how good my internet connection will be
at the place i will be staying I think
it might be okay so maybe i can i can do
a quick video here and down just say a
quick hello my video but i'm not sure if
i'm going to manage to to make some yeah
normal full scale updates for instance
for the opening series but i'll try yeah
thanks for watching and talk to you soon
I guess